many syrians know the loss of loved ones
only too well
in the town of genderes in the Northwest
more than a decade of Civil War has
already killed and displaced many
but those who have survived are now
living through a new trauma the Region's
earthquakes disaster
across the border in Turkey rescue and
Aid operations are running Non-Stop
but here there is only silence and
feelings of grief and abandonment
could only watch helplessly as his son
slowly died trapped together under W for
hours he hugged his child and waited for
help but none arrived we had development
First Blood oozed out of my son's mouth
and then his voice fighter gradually my
daughter and other son would just made
his way they also died they only asked
for help from God
says no Aid can heal his wounds
he has lost what he treasured most his
children Northwest Syria is home to more
than 4 million people it has been
heavily bombed by the regime throughout
12 year long Civil War life here was
already tough and the earthquake has
just added to their misery these
children were born during Syria's War
most have grown up as orphans
they have washed those around them
killed by bombs falling from the sky
the earthquakes took away what little
they had left
but even in disaster some are finding
fun in this makeshift Camp it's now home
to many survivors
one of them is Muhammad satuf he had a
family and lived in a camp it wasn't
much but still home
he says he was next to his wife when the
roof collapsed on them
he held his wife's leg to see if she was
alive
she moved it a little a sign of Life a
spark of hope when he walked in a
makeshift hospital he discovered his
entire family was dead
I asked about my wife the doctor told me
she is dead my daughter is dead my son
too they are all gone
four kilometers away in cavar Safra life
and death are intertwined Sabah Hussein
lost many friends and family members
during the war now the earthquake has
claimed nine more
you see how many people are now in need
of help they also lost their families We
buried our loved ones here her husband
lies buried next to some of their
children
but she says she must stay strong her
youngest child still needs her
people here say the International
Community has abandoned them but they
are used to being ignored now though
they feel angered by the absence of help
although International Aid is finally
arriving they say it is too little too
late but what there is they will need to
survive the winter we had to cross the
border before the day ended we passed
several checkpoints as the sun sat
living behind a country where disaster
after disaster overlap Russo Sardar Al
Jazeera genderes Northwest Syria